it's a friend of the show and had a
pretty good day yesterday biking's
quarterback Case Keenum joining us case
good morning how much sleep last night
not a lot woke up early and then and
couldn't go back to sleep man I still
still got a lot of people I need a call
back and takes but minutes it's still
it's still sinking in how many text
messages after the game I'm about 250
[Laughter]
okay take us in the huddle with ten
seconds to go
and I want to know where your confidence
level is be honest with me and then I
want to know what the play call is what
take us in and then we'll let it unfold
from there you know man
they asked me to remember last night and
like I barely remember the huddle I
remember calling the play you know at
that point you're kind of just you know
scratching and clawing just just trying
to trying to get the ball off trying to
get it downfield you know trying to give
your guy a chance
I mean I remember telling those guys
like hey let's you know I'm gonna give
you give one of you guys a chance y'all
stay up here ready to go and yeah I mean
it was it was absolutely nuts but was
whoever caught it were they and
instructed to go out of bounds so you
get a chance for a last-second field
goal yeah we were in a we were in a mode
for you know get out of bound this we
call it you know we have it we have a
code name for it but it's just basically
hey if you catch the ball get out of
bounds like with only more timeouts it's
just kind of a an alert for those guys
to know that they need to get our bounds
and I mean I think everybody in the
stadium was yelling at Diggs to get out
of bounds and then half second later
everybody's yelling at him to run so
it's pretty pretty incredible moment
pretty incredible play when did you
realize you just won the game when you
throw the ball I don't know if your view
is obstructed there and then you see
Diggs and then all of a sudden you're
kind of looking up and then you take
your helmet off like wait we just won
this game
yeah I saw him go for the ball I'm out I
let it go and I knew it was gonna be in
a good spot and I see him go for the
ball I always got a chance at this he
comes down with it and I was only caught
it get out of bounds and then and then
he turns and he falls and he puts his
hand down and I'm I'm gonna and at that
point he's running to the end zone and
everybody's going crazy and I think it's
yeah like like you said I was just I
don't even have words for it man I just
I couldn't believe what was happening I
didn't know what was happening and it
just it was unbelievable what did you
think when the Saints went down and took
the lead well when we you talk about the
first time no no the the light when you
were down you know so when you finally
get the ball back after Brees led them
down and they kick the field goal what
were you thinking well I mean obviously
we you know we went down and got a still
going I hope I felt good about that
drive you know putting our putting
ourselves in a chance to win and you
know something you always want to do is
lead lead drives like that in important
times but you know with with trees with
with what Drew Brees having the ball
back I've got a lot of confidence our
defense but I mean he he made some huge
plays and I mean it was it was tough to
watch you know because he's just so
clutch there and you know making that
field goal it's you know it was tough to
watch I'm a million emotions going
through my mind and it's it's hard to
put into words right now Dan I can't
it's still Allstate sinking in but
you're watching this game and Joe Buck
made a great call he said I think that
both teams have this scenario the way
they wanted with the ball with Drew
Brees and the Vikings defense out there
and then all of a sudden they get the
field goal they take the lead and all of
a sudden I'm looking at I don't know if
you've seen the video of you on the
sidelines like you're just you're
nervous as can be when Brees has the
ball like oh my god that's the last guy
you want out there with the ball in the
situation and then all of a sudden you
realize I got to go back out there and
try to make something happen in ten
seconds so it was this range of emotion
there of I'm watching I'm nervous I
can't doing about it
now I have to do something and go out
there and try to try to get us in field
range pretty amazing you know turn of
events there for you yeah it was it was
a rollercoaster you know to go out there
and get the drive get our field goal to
go up you know obviously was I mean that
was awesome and then you know when
they're driving you know I'm you know
kind of you know pray and hate one time
defense Taiwanese one time one more time
and then they get the third and two
third and three I think on in field goal
range and I think there's about 33
seconds left and I'm like okay we've got
two timeouts and we're gonna stop him
here and okay Chris no goal
okay we're gonna have one timeout with
about 20 25 28 seconds left and that's
that's kind of when I turn it back on I
was like okay like we gotta be ready to
go for this thing right here
McLovin has a question for you we're
talking to Case Keenum of the Vikings
yes we haven't it's serious football X's
and O's so win or lose next week case
where am I staying Super Bowl week in
Minnesota they downstairs guest room or
the upstairs bedroom what when I
crashing at your place
oh there's unfortunately Hotel hotel
keenham Super Bowl week you're booked up
already yeah we had some pre-booking
when I told you in July exactly how this
play you said well if that happens you
can crash in my house remember that
conversation I mean I do have a garage
it's not heated air man in there son
did Mike Zimmer smile after last night's
game case yeah oh you did did anybody
get a picture like it's it's elusive you
can't get it in a picture it's
impossible - when do you watch film of
this game I'll watch it i watch it here
a little bit I just got in my family
left this morning you know we I think
the meet here in a couple hours
go over the film and then you know it's
on to the on to the next one
yeah and you got to tell yourself and
everybody else that you got to like you
can only enjoy this for
so long and then all of a sudden like
you've got it like two more hours you
get to enjoy this and then all of a
sudden Mike Zimmer is gonna bring you
back to reality and say all right let's
look at the Eagles here yep 24-hour rule
man I think I think we got a few more
hours on that but you know we got a we
got a really really cool opportunity
ahead of us and it'd be a shame to waste
you know waste with what's happened so
far it was fun happy for you and good
luck against the Eagles and we'll see
you in Minneapolis
thanks Dan appreciate it man see you see
in Minneapolis McLovin there you go okay
Scott yeah for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]